Ukraine's military says it destroyed
almost 70 aerial targets
launched by Russia
in its latest onslaught overnight.
And that includes more than three dozen
cruise missiles,
as well as Iranian made drones
and a reconnaissance drone.
A police official in Kiev says
residential buildings and infrastructure
in several districts were damaged,
but no one was killed or injured.
This comes just a day after Ukraine said
Russia had launched one of its
largest
drone attacks to date against Kiev.
CNN some analysis is in London
with the very latest for you.
Somehow Russia
ramping up missile and drone strikes
targeting the Ukrainian capital
just as crowds were marking Kiev day.
Yes. So yet again overnight
there was a huge assault
by Russia on Ukraine, as you mentioned.
Some 67 air targets shot down,
according to Ukrainian officials.
37 cruise missiles
and 29 drones were destroyed.
Ukrainian officials
say that this latest assault was targeting
military facilities
and critical infrastructure.
And it comes, as you mentioned,
just a day after on Sunday,
Ukraine saw the largest assault
since the conflict began by drones.
Some 59 drones were shot
at Ukraine on Sunday.
All but one were shot down.
So there's a couple of things
to take away from from this news,
from this information, as you mentioned.
It appears that Russia is ramping up
its attacks far from the front lines.
Of course, this serves to terrorize
the citizens of Ukraine who are, again,
not on that battlefield,
but it also expands Ukraine's
very valuable munitions
When you think about the drones
in particular, these are very low cost.
They cost about 20 times less than
the missiles required to take them out.
So it's a way of forcing Ukraine
to expend very valuable resources.
But for Ukrainian officials,
what they take away from
this is that their air
defense systems are working.
Is that those weapons that help
that poured in
from Nieto and its allies,
those are effective.
Those are saving lives.
If you take, again, the example of the air
assault today.
So far, no reports of casualties.
That means they're able to be effective
in taking out.
Again, these huge barrages
that are being fired by Russia.
And so what more have you been able
to learn about these series of explosions
that have happened in and around
the Russian occupied cities of Mariupol?
So both Ukrainian backed officials
and Russian backed officials
giving indications
that the cities of Mariupol
and burned down were sites of exclusion
over the course of the last day.
What we understand and again, it's
great for you to pull up the map there
because these are two very important
cities, critical cities on the Sea
of Azov.
Mariupol in particular,
of course, has become emblematic
to Ukrainians of the brutality
of Russian forces after it was taken
in a monthslong siege last year
at the beginning of the conflict,
it is very much Russian occupied.
So is Verdansk right now
Ukrainian backed officials there
saying that they were targeting sites
for the Russian military
in both those locations, at least
five sites were targeted in Verdun.
Another site was targeted in Mariupol.
Russian officials did indicate that
their air defense systems were activated.
What does all of this mean?
It means potentially
that we're looking at Ukrainian forces
conducting what they call
shaping operation.
So taking up critical infrastructure,
critical Russian positions
ahead of this counteroffensive.
Again, Alina, some of these reporting,
thank you for your continued coverage.
So that
sound in there, you can see
as it lights up those images
of Ukrainian forces repelling an intense
barrage of Russian drone attacks.
Ukraine's military says its forces
shot down nearly 70 drones
that were targeting Kiev.
It's being called Russia's largest attack
to date on the capital city
using Iranian made drones notably.
And it comes as CNN teams on the ground
heard several explosions in
Kiev overnight.
Now, these Russian attacks also come
as Ukraine nears the launch of this
long awaited counteroffensive
we've been talking about.
One of Ukraine's top generals recently
posted this highly produced video.
It shows Ukrainian troops
preparing for battle and ends with troops
chanting a message that calls for victory
for a decisive offensive.
Joining us now with more, retired U.S.
Army Major Mike Lyons.
Good to see you. As always.
So when we
when we talk about this, what would this
potential counter offensive at this point?
What would it look like?
Yeah, just look at a map.
You can see Russian forces
in two separate locations.
I believe any counteroffensive
is going to cut these Russian forces
in half here and threaten Crimea.
I think that is the issue here
for the Ukrainian forces.
But they're not going to do that
until they have the combined arms,
the shock effect, the tanks,
helicopters, Bradley fighting vehicles,
more men, more equipment.
Russia still has had setbacks.
Lost a lot of men, low morale,
but they're still Russia.
They could go on the active defense and
they still are very formidable opponent.
They certainly have time on their side.
They can wait it out a bit longer in terms
of the counter-offensive and whether
whether plays a critical role
and when we start to see that offensive.
Explain to us how weather plays
into all this Yes, weather and terrain.
It's part of a commander's assessment
with regard to the tactical situation
on the ground.
On a ground war, though not
like D-Day, for example, when weather
really impact the seas and the like.
I think what you're going to see here,
the soil
where there's concern that, for example,
a satellite images show
that the soil is hardening up.
It's a little better.
That will provide, again, those tanks
a little more mobility on the ground.
The Ukraine military has the advantage.
That's a home.
Then they know the terrain.
They know where the bridges are.
They know where things are going.
But I think it's still a small effect.
I think the combat forces
are really more important.
I say. So give us a sense of of timing.
I feel that we've been talking about this
for a long time,
this potential counteroffensive.
Are we approaching the right moment?
Yeah. We go back to you.
Go back to that
and you have to say that again.
They're not going to put their troops in
a situation where they're going to fail.
They need to succeed.
They do pick the time.
They pick the pace and location.
I'm not sure they have enough troops
ready to go.
We haven't seen, for example, reports
of massing of equipment
in this in the areas in the south.
We hear a lot of reports
about what's going on in this part
here in back mount in the west.
But again, from from my perspective,
from a military perspective,
I think this is where
the counter-offensive takes place.
And we don't have that equipment
there yet.
It's not ready to go.
Any sense of when it might be?
Because, I mean, the spring offensive,
I think strategically
is really important for Ukraine
to be able to show that they can do this.
Well, I think let's say
let's give it another 90 days
and assess the situation there.
You still have these crews, for example,
some of the weapons systems, for example,
the tanks, the leopard, the Abrams.
These are the things that are going
to make a difference.
These are the shock effects
that will make a difference on the ground.
And they're just not there training
troops and grief and fear.
We have troops in the United States still.
The Patriot missiles have been effective.
The way Ukraine wins is a combined arms
fight and synchronizing all these troops.
That takes time.